hugo et gabriel se prépare à partir pour
une course de 10 km mais ils ne sont pas
seuls en situation de handicap ils ont
besoin de leurs coéquipiers pour pousser
leurs joëlette sorte de fauteuil roulant
tout terrain et violette est donc un
engin à une roue qui permet d'emmener
des jeunes à mobilité réduite sur les
routes dans les forêts dans les
montagnes dans les collines il faut une
personne qui pousse une personne qui
tire et ont fait avancer la violette et
on se relaye entre coureurs de
participer à ces événements sportifs en
se dépassant et de manière collective ça
me paraît être la meilleure manière pour
apprendre à vivre ensemble pour lui
c'est super intéressant parce que comme
sa maladie en soi c'est un manque
d'énergie il sait qu'il peut pas faire
de sport qui peut pas courir qui peut
pas voilà des déployer de force dans
l'activité sportive il est conscient que
le fait qu'on court pour lui ou concours
avec lui aux confins du vélo ça apporte
de l'énergie et ça apporte de l'énergie
ma financière et physique et mentale ses
membres habitués ou débutants de
l'association dunes d'espoir permettent
à des personnes handicapées de faire des
courses habituellement réservé aux
valides 35 kg a poussé c'est physique
mais ses accompagnateurs donc un
challenge faire sourire le pilote d'un
effort collectif puisque on se relaie
autour de la joëlette avec le pilote et
qu'on arrive on part ensemble en
arrivent ensemble c'est aussi ça qui
fait la force de cet exercice on se dit
que si un dimanche matin on doit se
lever pour aller courir autant de le
faire
deux façons de façon joyeuse souvent
quand il pas le soleil on se dit que le
soleil il est là et dans nos coeurs dans
le coeur des enfants et dans leurs
sourires delà des sensations qui
plaisent copilote
[Musique]
le sourire du jeune voyait le sourire du
jeune de l'énergie à tous les coureurs
ont chantée on crie on fait les fous ils
étaient super contents il ya le fait de
faire partir à d'un groupe vous faites
on voit aller parce qu'il couvre il ya
tout le monde qui dit à l'ego c'est
beaucoup de bonheur une activité de
partage pour tout le monde grâce à la
joëlette et qui se déroulent tout au
long de l'année dans les yvelines et en
dehors avec dunes d'espoir